Speaker 1: It's great to welcome back to the
program today Bill Share contributor to the
Washington Monthly Politico and real clear
politics.
Also host of the history podcast When America
Worked.
Bill, always great to have you on.
And we're welcoming your dog today as well.
Speaker 3: Yes, if you can see in the corner
here, Nova is chewing on some plastic.
Yes.
Hopefully I'll keep you occupied.
Speaker 1: Let's hope so.
So let's let's just start with the outlook
for the next two years.
I mean, interesting Wall Street Journal op
ed yesterday about Republicans being too dimwitted
to really wield the power that they're going
to have and how they're fighting over MCCARTHY
And it's just kind of becoming a mess.
Of course, Republicans will narrowly control
the House.
They will not control the Senate.
It looked like the Senate would be 51 to 49,
and it sort of is.
Although Kirsten Cinema now says she's going
to be an independent, but seemingly will not
dramatically change how she plans to vote.
I think maybe, although I'm not completely
sure about that.
So like what?
Is anything going to happen in the next two
years legislatively that is significant.
Speaker 3: I mean, you know, media, but I'm
a fairly optimistic person.
But, you know, you know, I'm saying my expectations
are very, very low for this Congress.
I mean, if they can keep the lights on and
avoid a debt default, you know, congratulations.
Yeah.
Still works.
Speaker 1: If there is a utility for 24 for
each party from what does or doesn't happen
over the next two years, it seems clear that
Republicans are going to want to make the
case in 24 that that Democrats didn't get
anything done in this two year period and
that things got worse.
That may be by their own doing, of course,
as often is in politics.
Is that the type of thing that is likely to
swing a presidential election like the one
we would see in 24, a sort of referendum on
what Democrats got done when they held one
of two houses and had Joe Biden in the White
House.
Or is that just not likely to be a very impactful
argument, two years, 23 months from now?
Speaker 3: Well, generally speaking, you know,
assuming Biden runs.
Yes, nominee.
Yes, you would assume that 2012 will be a
referendum on him.
That's typically how reelections go.
And something that I talked about over the
course of the past year.
Midterms are not really referendums on the
president.
That's a bit of a misnomer.
Yep.
And and I think that has been borne out in
this passage because Joe Biden's approval
was not good.
But, you know, midterms I mean, this is not,
you know, a settled argument, but there is
an argument that I embrace that they're about
balance and an electorate trying to balance
things out from the past election and kind
of keep things roughly in the middle, which
is why the opposition party tends to do well
irrespective of presidential approval.
And that didn't happen this time, I would
argue, because the balancing choice was the
Democrats, because Republicans put up candidates
who were essentially imbalanced and were doing
disruptive things.
And now that's spooked that much of the electorate.
And it speaks to a an intraparty conflict
with Republicans.
Mitch McConnell, whom Democrats looked at
as, you know, a obstructionist extraordinaire,
had a different take on how to handle Joe
Biden the past two years, which was.
Let's have a modicum of cooperation.
Let's.
I hate shutdown.
Shutdowns always make us look bad.
Let's.
Let's do the bare minimum.
Let's do the infrastructure.
Let's do the semiconductor investments to
compete with China.
Let's partner on Ukraine.
And we can fight Democrats on a bunch of other
things where we think they're going too far
to the left.
And the Trump forces didn't subscribe to that.
They were mad at McConnell for being as cooperative
as he was.
They put up a slate of Senate candidates who
are totally out to lunch, who were caught
up on election denial and other culture war
type things.
And that gave room for the Democrats say,
look, we're trying to keep things on the on
the straight and narrow here.
And these people want to, you know, you know,
break all the china.
So now you're going into a Congress where,
again, you know, Mitch McConnell can't dictate
what the party strategy is because you have
this narrowly controlled house.
Although I should I should caveat here.
We don't even know what the speaker's going
to be.
Speaker 1: Correct.
Speaker 3: So, you know, if it's McCarthy,
Kevin McCarthy and if Kevin McCarthy is beholden
to the far right, then you have this open
question.
Can you keep the lights on?
Can you avoid a government shutdown?
Can't you raise the debt limit to avoid a
global economic destroying debt default?
That becomes a big unknown if the anti McCarthy
faction makes it impossible for McCarthy to
get the.
Teeny needs.
There is this threat from the moderate splinter
faction of the Republican Party led by your
Don Bacon begins with the most vocal about
this, saying if these guys push you push us
too far will partner with Democrats and put
up a bi partizan speaker, a Republican, but
someone who is not beholden to the far, far
right.
And if that's the case that maybe we're open
for business, that maybe we actually can pass
a few things, and maybe McConnell would be
willing to do some bare minimum stuff again.
So Republicans don't seem like they're insane.
Speaker 1: On the Kirsten cinema situation.
There's basically every analysis under the
sun.
This was done and timed in a way just to upset
Democrats, which doesn't seem to I mean, it
seems strategically like it leaves a little
something to be desired in terms of an explanation.
There's the Arizona explanation, which is
cinema was facing a challenge from a progressive
Democrat.
By becoming an independent, she's able to
short circuit that possibility and maybe turn
it into a three way race in which the incumbent
independent easily wins reelection in Arizona.
That's another possibility.
Three is she just really wants attention.
And when it's 51 to 49, the way to get attention
back is to at least threaten that.
Maybe it's actually 5050 again.
What's your best assessment of the timing
and the decision?
Speaker 3: You know, I'm someone who has defended
cinema over the course of the past years.
She's arguably the most effective legislature
the Democrats have had.
I know the counterargument is, will she, you
know, kneecapped their dream agenda?
So don't give her credit for passing something
smaller.
But part of that argument was that it was
impossible to get the 60 odd things you McConnell
wouldn't let you get the 60 on infrastructure
or gun safety or the Electoral Count Act or
what have you.
And that proved not to be true.
Cinema was the person doing those deals, actually
doing the negotiations and finding the common
ground.
So I think she deserves credit for that.
And I think she has taken away the wrong lesson.
From that experience, she was able to do what
she did because she could bank on 50 Democrats
ripe for whatever compromise she hashed out
because there was an intrinsic, you know,
we you know, parties tend to be favorable
to their incumbents, assuming they're going
to be the nominees that Arizona's a closely
divided state.
You can't again, Democrat can't guarantee
to win a statewide election there.
If she is your best bet, you will go along
with her on her deals in hopes that she keeps
that seat for Democrats.
Now, maybe she's not.
She she won't be the Democratic nominee.
Maybe Democrats can put up a nominee that
can be competitive in a three way race.
And so it puts Democrats in an awkward position
with her.
And so her deals I mean, the challenge her
before was convincing ten Republicans.
This is in your interest, you know, is better
for you to do this infrastructure deal or
do this gun safety deal.
That is not I know we're going to fight on
Election Day, but you'll be in a worse position
if you fight me on this, which is hard enough.
But she did that.
Now she has to fight a two front war to pass
any kind of deal again.
Mind you wouldn't even know what kind of situation
the House is going to be in, if it's going
to be hospitable to deals.
Her political value is I'm the person that
gets things done.
If she's no longer that person, then she has
a harder argument to make.
And so I if I was advising her a month ago,
I'd say, You know what?
Why don't you wait and see what happens with
the speaker's race?
Right.
Why don't you wait and see if you can get
a couple more deals under your belt for.
Actually, why don't you do a little outreach
to Democrats in Arizona and say, hey, look,
this is why am I thinking that?
I mean, there are other Democrats that break
ranks from time to time and you have nearly
as much upset with the base as similar in
Arizona because she hasn't done that outreach.
And and so I hate to play, you know, armchair
psychologist with this stuff, but you look
at the recent reporting that The Washington
Post did on this, which suggests that this
was sort of in the making for a long time.
And I just kind of come down to I just think
she don't like the attention argument because
she's do a lot of media.
I think she does a lot of things that don't
attract attention.
But I do think she likes being a party of
one.
She likes follow her own compos.
She doesn't like having to play the footsie
with the elements in the base that don't get
what she's doing.
And so she made a decision that's comfortable
for her, but I don't really think is the right
strategy, both legislatively and politically.
Speaker 1: I am no cinema fan by any means,
but I do find interesting that for a while
now there have been a lot of people saying
cinema shouldn't be in the Democratic Party
because she's not really a Democrat.
You hear sometimes they say the same thing
about Joe Manchin.
The people who didn't want her to be a Democrat
have sort of won in the sense that now she
isn't a Democrat, but now they're still mad.
And there's some there's something interesting
about that.
But as I've said before, you know, when people
talk about you got a primary, Joe Manchin
with a progressive, if a progressive defeats
Joe Manchin in a primary in West Virginia,
I don't see any way that that progressive
wins.
I think that that seat becomes a Republican
seat.
Arizona's dynamics are different than West
Virginia, and an actual bona fide three way
race is a very different situation than Manchin
being primaried by a progressive.
But there is some state level strategy here
that is at least a little more connected to
reality than the West Virginia Manchin thing,
it seems to me.
Speaker 3: Well, I. Yes, yes and no.
I mean, obviously, Arizona is not as red as
most West Virginia is.
Yeah.
Now, progressives have challenge Manchin in
primaries.
Manchin stops them.
Yes.
Goes on to win.
Look, Arizona, if it's blue, it is just barely
blue.
Even this past election.
Look, Democrats managed to win governor and
Senate, but not.
Speaker 1: House.
Right.
Speaker 3: The House popular vote was Republican.
And even if you make some ask because there
are a couple uncontested races, if you some
estimates, there probably would still have
an edge in the popular vote.
You know, Republicans put up truly insane
candidates for a swing state and got burned.
If they learned their lesson and put up, you
know, center right candidates, you can't count
on any old Democrat holding on to any seat
in Arizona.
So the notion that I mean, yes, cinema's numbers
are bad.
And I think she did things that I think her
issue set is perfectly fine for Arizona.
I think her legacy of success is excellent
for Arizona.
I think the optics she's chosen to do along
with that have been terrible and somewhat
self-sabotaging.
And so it puts her in a precarious position.
But if you get Ruben Gallego or Greg Stanton
and that person can get, you know, 33 races
is such a jump ball.
Yeah, you have no idea.
First, you've no idea.
Are you going to carry L.A., Doug Ducey type
on the Republican side?
That's a huge difference.
And we really don't know.
You can't look at a poll today and really
know how much is sort of a pull from the Republican
the center right of the center left.
I mean, I wouldn't be optimistic about it,
to be honest, because you look at the races
where independents have won.
Typically speaking, one party's candidate
just tax write, making it easier to independently
pick up the lion's share of one party's votes.
There are a couple of ones I'm aware of where
an independent one with credible Republican
Democratic candidates, one is Angus King.
Yet in Maine, when he when he ran and he won
that governor's race by a hair and then when
he ran for Senate, it was much easier for
him.
But he just but you're talking getting in
the upper thirties to win that kind of race.
The other one is Jesse Ventura, governor of
Minnesota.
Well, I know a little bit more about the fascinating
about the Jesse Ventura race is the main reason
why he won.
It was same day registration.
Right.
70% of his vote was same day registrations.
And who were they?
Twentysomething white, male wrestling fans.
Like, it's not it's not a typical kind of
race that you can model anything else after.
So you're cinema is is idiosyncratic case
because he's an incumbent and I'm not saying
she can't pull it off, but that's a real roll
of the dice.
And I, I would say I think he could do better.
Mending some fences with your Democratic base,
you can win that primary.
It's very unusual to lose a primary if you're
an incumbent.
So I think with little a little elbow grease,
she could have done that.
I mean, are life easier?
But obviously she made her choices.
Speaker 1: Well, I don't really make predictions,
but I will predict that cinema's fate will
not be to be in Baja California, off the grid,
surfing and doing conspiracy theories like
Jesse Ventura ended up after his gubernatorial
run.
Bill Share, contributor to Washington Monthly,
POLITICO, Real Clear Politics and also host
of the history podcast One America Worked.
Bill, always a pleasure having you on.
Speaker 3: Same here.
Take care.
Happy holidays.